des premières projections de 10 920 à
celle d'aujourd'hui en très haute
définition le grenier à sel à trappes
aura connu toutes les évolutions
technologiques du cinéma baptisé le
normandie en 1964 son écran courbe
l'heracles orama avec son impression de
relief séduit les spectateurs depuis
2012 et sous son nom de cinéma jean
renoir c'est avec sa diffusion des films
en quatre cas qu'il fait venir le public
4k comprenait une définition d'image
environ deux fois supérieure à celle des
télévisions full hd de nos salons on a
encore eu il n'y a pas très longtemps là
avec la sortie du film amours danacol
qui celui qui a eu la balle madore qui
était en 4k on a eu des gens qui
sortaient le spectateur qui sortait et
qui était bluffé mais c'est quoi cette
image parce que effectivement le film
était incroyable c'était la plus belle
définition n'est jusqu'à présent jusqu'à
jusqu'au film que ce soir ça me sarah ça
marche comment fait on va remplacer la
pellicule par un des disques durs ou de
ce qu'on appelle les dcp donc un format
d'encodage qui est propre au cinéma et
on va donc chargé le disque dur ou le
contenu directement sur le serveur et
l'espace de stockage du de la partie
projection du projecteur ou alors on
peut recevoir de manière dématérialisée
par ou par satellite ou par adsl
les films mais ce sont les fichiers très
lourd on 150 gia de lourds
investissements ont été nécessaires le
projecteur avoisine les 60 mille euros
ajoutez à cela les travaux d'électricité
ou encore de ventilation et la facture
monte à 100 mille euros reste à
rentabiliser l'opération puisque les
autres cinémas s'équipent à leur tour
signer c'est à elle en cours ou salle
jacques brel à montigny le bretonneux et
c'est une nouvelle guerre entre
exploitants qui débute à celui qui
offrira le meilleur confort visuel et
auditif
sachez que si vous souhaitez rivaliser
il vous faudra mettre la main à la poche
les premiers téléviseur 4k arrive mais
ils ne sont pas vraiment bon marché
le premier modèle est 1,84 pouces qui
est aux alentours de 25 mille euros donc
ce qui nous paraît vraiment excessif
effectivement donc réservé
malheureusement à certains seulement
nous sortons la actuellement de
nouvelles télés de nouveaux téléviseurs
plus économique et on devrait être aux
alentours de entre 10 et 15 euros